5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Ja.
Das ist nicht besonders viel. Was sind das für Leute und was genau macht ihr da?
Also, erstmal ist hier Joe, unser Geschäftsführer. Der hat das bis vor einem Jahr noch ganz alleine geschmissen, hier den Laden. Und im letzten September sind halt dann noch Marie und ich hinzugekommen. Und ja, wir stehen kurz vor dem Umzug. Also wir hoffen, dass wir ein bisschen größer werden können jetzt in der nächsten Zeit, weil wir wirklich in Arbeit hier untergehen. Also das ist nicht nur CleanIT, das sind noch ganz viele andere schöne Projekte. Und wie ich am Anfang schon mal erklärt habe, machen wir ja nicht nur, beobachten wir ja nicht nur so komische Projekte wie CleanIT, sondern auch machen auch Urheberrecht, Datenschutz, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, alles Mögliche.
Also das sozusagen, was man hier in Deutschland möglicherweise als Internetaktivismus bezeichnen würde. Aber kannst du konkret sagen, wie sieht so ein Arbeitstag von dir aus? Also vielleicht, was hast du heute gemacht?
Heute immer anders. Also jeder Tag ist wirklich anders. Manchmal laufen wir halt in Anhörungen im europäischen Parlament und schreiben alles mit und teilen das dann, was hier so abläuft, unseren Mitgliedern, unseren nationalen Mitgliedern mit. Und manchmal treffen wir uns ganz persönlich mit Abgeordneten oder aber auch Kommissionsvertretern.
Jetzt gibt es da sozusagen Politiker, mit denen ihr redet oder wo ihr hört, was die sagen. Aber ihr seid ja wahrscheinlich nicht die Einzigen, die ihr nennt, das ist Advocacy. Die anderen machen dann Lobbyarbeit betreiben.
Was gibt es da noch für Leute in Brüssel? Das Problem, das das EDRI hat, ist, dass wir schon seit sehr langer Zeit die einzige netzpolitische Organisation hier in Brüssel sind. Das ändert sich jetzt so langsam. Wenn man allein die ganzen Lobbyisten aus der Unterhaltungsindustrie zusammenrechnet, kommt man auf mehrere hunderte. Bei der Sicherheitsindustrie sind das bestimmt noch mehr. Die haben natürlich auch ganz andere finanzielle Mittel.
Brüssel, ist das so eine Stadt, in die es dich eh verschlagen hätte? Oder musstest du da sehr bewusst hingehen? Hat das irgendwie mehr Gründe, so jetzt in die EU-Stadt da hinzugehen? Oder für den Autonormaleuro-Politiker hätte der dann auch in Brüssel etwas anderes machen können? Oder kann man sich das schwer vorstellen? Ist es eine schöne Stadt oder ist es irgendwie noch anders spannend?
Also ich glaube, das ist ganz objektiv. Also ich finde Brüssel super, weil es wirklich total multikulturell hier ist. Also nicht nur durch die Brussels-Bubble, wie wir das nennen. Ich glaube, andere finden Brüssel nicht so schön, weil es hier ziemlich viel regnet. Aber ja, ich wollte halt, also ich habe vorher im Süden Europas gewohnt und wollte halt einfach wieder in den Norden hoch.
Okay, wenn man in Brüssel ist, merkt man, dass das wie weiß eigentlich Berlin ist von den Leuten. In Brüssel gibt es Schokolade, Bier und Pommes. Das ist auch noch eine Attraktion neben der ganz hübschen Innenstadt. Aber die meisten Lobbyisten sind tatsächlich in dieser Bubble, in diesem Europaviertel. Das sind aber nicht andere, großartig andere Politiker, als die, die es auch nach Berlin in den Bundestag verschlägt, von ihren Landkreisen über ganz Deutschland. Die sind dann eben nur aus ganz Europa. Aber da sind auch die unterschiedlichsten Menschen dabei, je nach Partei und je nach Interessenslage.
Aber trotzdem gibt es ja immer wieder diese Vorschläge, Projekte, Initiativen, was auch immer, die mit dem, was ihr wahrscheinlich in Beschneidung des Internets zu tun haben. Was ist denn das für ein Schlag von Menschen, der in Brüssel arbeitet? Was ist denn das für ein Beet, in dem man immer wieder geboren wird? Woran liegt das?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht auf Brüssel begrenzt. Wenn die deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft sowas sagt, dann sagen wir ja auch nicht, das ist im Internet geboren oder in Deutschland geboren.
Aber es ist ja schon so, Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben wir dann mal hier abgeklärt.
Das ist immer ein guter Punkt, dass du die Vorratsdatenspeicherung erwähnst, weil das war ja damals das erste Mal, dass wir da von der EU auch kalt erwischt worden sind. Da gab es hier so ein paar Sicherheitspolitiker, die es nicht geschafft haben, das Vorratsdatenspeicherungsäquivalent dort im Telekommunikationsgesetz unterzubringen, weil der Bundesrat gesagt hat, spinnst du? Und daraufhin wurde dann dieser europäische Umweg beschritten und die Vorratsdatenspeicherung als Richtlinie der EU verabschiedet. Und Deutschland sollte das implementieren. Und dann kam plötzlich Vorratsdatenspeicherung als deutsches Gesetz und wurde vom Verfassungsgericht kassiert. Und ja, der Hacker-Szene und digitalen Szene ist es damals echt übel aufgestoßen. Und dort ist dann auch das Bewusstsein geschärft worden, dass wir da mal gucken müssen, wenn die EU irgendwas bestimmen kann, was Deutschland umsetzen muss, was aber unseren Interessen wirklich konträr entgegenläuft, dann muss man da vielleicht schon vorher ansetzen. Und das war auch dann im Club die Initialzündung, um EDRI unterstützen zu wollen.
Ja, also bei allen Sachen, die wir heute besprochen haben, weil ich meine natürlich Herr Weiser, aber das hat ja schon so den Eindruck, als ob das sozusagen in Brüssel alles seinen Anfang findet.
Nö, das findet den Anfang nur, weil es halt bequemer ist. Ich meine, so einfach an einer zentralen Stelle Gesetze zu erlassen, um sich dann einfach im nationalen Parlament nicht mehr darum kümmern zu müssen, ob das so mit den Grundrechten vereinbar ist, ist doch dann deutlich bequemer.
Ja, aber die Sache ist ja die Sache, was ich sozusagen von außen erlebe, ist folgendes. In der EU wird genau immer so ein Gesetz ausgebracht, genau aus dem Grund, weil wenn man es da macht, dann hat man es gleich für alle EU-Staaten, schon einfach. Aber es fällt dann immer auch auf mehr oder weniger fruchtbaren Boden, nicht fruchtigen. Und es sieht für mich aus, als würde ich sagen, es gibt immer diese langen, langen, langen Kämpfe von Aktivisten, die sozusagen dagegen vorgehen und irgendwie Leute auf die Straße ziehen und Politiker beklien und dann so nach langem wirklich elend langen Zerren, dann wird so ein Ding mal wieder beerdigt und bam, drei Monate später kommt das nächste. Das ist sozusagen, das ist ja, da würde ich schon sagen, da läuft was falsch im Staat Brüssel.
Ja, ich glaube also, dass das Clean IT, dass das Problem ist, dass das halt nur ein Symptom eines allgemeinen Trends ist. Also schon seit einigen Jahren versuchen halt EU-Kommissionen, aber auch Mitgliedstaaten, US-Regierungen, sogar OECD immer wieder durch die verschiedensten Projekte halt Unternehmen irgendwie zu Polizeirichter und Henker gleichzeitig im Internet zu machen. Und genauso gibt es jetzt auch zwei weitere Projekte, die ähnlich ist wie Clean IT planen. Also das sind einmal, Andre hat es eben schon erwähnt, die CEO-Collision und die ICT-Collision.
CEO haben wir schon gehört, da geht es um Kinderschutz vorgeblich. Was war das andere?
Genau, ICT-Collision ist so ähnlich wie die CEO-Collision, aber irgendwie auch noch was anderes. Und da geht es auch um Kinder- und Jugendschutz. Irgendwie muss man mal was machen, damit unsere Kinder sicherer sind. Und da hat sich die Kommission halt auch verschiedene Industriepartner zusammen gerufen.
Der Trend der Privatisierung, der Rechtsvorsetzung, den sehen wir tatsächlich in immer kürzeren Abständen immer häufiger auch in der EU, aber auch in Deutschland. Ich meine, habe vorhin die Debatte schon mal angesprochen, die Debatte um Zensursula und die Netzsperren gegen Internetpornografie, das war ein Vorschlag aus Deutschland. Den mussten wir hier bekämpfen. Das war auch Privatisierung der Rechtsvorsetzung. Ein Ministerium wollte einen Vertrag mit Providern machen und die sollten Seiten sperren, auch ganz ohne Gesetz. Jetzt haben wir verschiedene Initiativen von Two, Three Strikes oder was sich die Contentindustrie da gerne wünscht, dass Provider ihre Nutze überwachen sollen und dann denen irgendwelche Warnhinweise schicken sollen. Das sind alles Symptome der Bekämpfung der Verlagerung der Rechtsvorsetzung auf private Unternehmen, die wir in Brüssel sehen, die wir aber auch genauso in Berlin sehen.
Würde ich halt sagen, also als Effizientdenken, Aktivistdenken, so ja okay, das kommt jetzt immer wieder. Lass uns doch mal die Wurzel des Übels finden und die einfach ausrotten.
Also die Wurzel des Übels erstmal zu benennen ist, glaube ich, wenn man da versucht ein Muster zu erkennen, ist mir jetzt just die Woche der Juristentag in Bayern. Die haben da irgendwie auch Dinge gefordert, die stehen da in Clean IT mit auch drinnen. Die wollten keinen anonymen Zugang mehr zum Internet, damit die Rechtsdurchsetzung allumfassend ist. Da muss man jetzt noch mal ganz kurz sich vergegenwärtigen. Die wollen einfach aus einer Fachidioten Blickrichtung einfach mal die Werkzeuge, die ihnen da Techniker, die genauso Fachidioten sind, erklärt haben. Es geht alles. Wir können dort plötzlich dieses Internet können wir, wir müssen nur ein bisschen hier an dem Algorithmus, da an dem Algorithmus, da kriegen wir total sicher. Und die Juristen gucken, oh, wir können da irgendwie endlich mal dieses juristische Regelwerk, was im alltäglichen Leben so ein bisschen komplex ist, weil da sind immer Menschen und die verhalten sich da irgendwie nicht so richtig, wie man das vielleicht mit juristischen Algorithmen beschreiben kann. Und da kommen die zusammen und fühlen sich da plötzlich wie im Himmel. Also ich glaube, es ist eher so Fachidiotentum auf höchstem Niveau. Man kann endlich da seinen Steckenpferd der gesamten Gesellschaft überhelfen und kann dort dann mit den technischen Möglichkeiten mal durchsetzen, was im richtigen Leben, also in der Offline-Welt, nicht so leicht durchdrückbar ist.
Also ich muss insofern zumindest mal nachfragen, dass ich doch ein paar Juristen und ein paar Techniker kennen, die sich jetzt sozusagen also verwehren würden, über diesen Kamm geschoren zu werden. Also der Schluss wäre, dass du sagst, okay, alle Juristen sind Politiker. Und die kennen so viele Techniker und deswegen kommen immer diese Vorschläge oder wie?
Nein, sie haben da jetzt mal just entdeckt. Da gibt es dieses Internet und dann haben sie das.
Die haben das jetzt entdeckt?
Na ja, so das Bewusstsein dämmert so langsam. So gerade die Älteren, die sich ihre E-Mails nicht mehr abtippen lassen von ihrer Sekretärin. Die haben dann irgendwie plötzlich auch noch mitbekommen, dass da irgendwie noch, das ist ja ein weites Feld und da passieren auch ganz doll böse Dinge. Aber eigentlich kann man das nicht regulieren, das ist ja alles elektronisch. Und dann sagt dir jemand, ja, das geht. Und ich glaube, dass dort einfach dieser blinde Glaube an das System, an den Computer, dass man dort einfach elektronische Systeme zur effizienten Rechtsdurchsetzung benutzen kann, dass der Glaube einfach tief verankert ist inzwischen. Und das ist eins der Grundübel, dass dort am Ende der Menschen nur noch, ja, peripher vorkommt und reguliert und in Bahnen gelenkt werden muss.
Kirsten, ist das denn bei euch dann so, dass ihr immer nur auf die Symptome gehen könnt? Also sozusagen, da kommt der nächste schlimme Vorschlag, da müssen wir jetzt wieder was machen und mal wieder mit den Politikern reden, um ihnen zu erklären, wie es wirklich ist. Oder kann man auch so eine Art Profilaxe bei Politikern betreiben und zu sagen, diesen Grundsatz, nämlich man will eigentlich kein kontrolliertes Internet irgendwie den nahe bringen?
Ganz viele Fragen in einem Satz. Ja, also ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich anfangen soll. Also wir arbeiten schon seit mehreren Jahren an diesem Problem der privatisierten Rechtsdurchsetzung und haben 2010 auch eine Studie dazu rausgegeben, die müssen wir eigentlich mal bearbeiten. Und ja, ich glaube, dass wir hier noch viel mehr Aufklärungsarbeit bei den Politikern einfach machen müssen. Also zum Beispiel die konservative EVP, also die Europäische Volkspartei, hier im Europaparlament hat das Internet wirklich erst im November letzten Jahres entdeckt und ihr Internetstrategiepapier veröffentlicht.
Aua, ich glaube auch, das ist eher das Problem, schon mal kurz den Sozialwissenschaftler heraushängen lassen. In unserer modernen Gesellschaft haben wir viele verschiedene Leute, die ihre ganz eigenen Zugänge zu verschiedenen politischen Themen finden. Und wir alle, die mit dem Internet aufgewachsen sind und es als völlig normalen Teil unseres Lebensalltags betrachten, wir sehen da die unglaublichen Möglichkeiten und die Chancen, wir nutzen das ganz selbstverständlich, ab und zu könnte mal ein Problem auftauchen, aber das kann man irgendwie auch lösen. Wenn man jetzt aber irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Politiker ist oder auch ein normaler Durchschnittsdeutscher, der ja langsam auf die Rente zugeht, noch nie großartig was mit diesem Internet zu tun gehabt hat, aber dann im Fernsehen hört, dass das alles ganz schlimm ist und dass sich da die Raubkopier-Mörder-Terroristen-Kinderschänder tummeln, dann muss man was dagegen tun. Und ob Brüssel oder Berlin, manche Politiker in den eher konservativen Parteien oder die nicht ganz so das Internet in den Lebensalltag aufgenommen haben, die tendieren dann eher dazu, die Probleme zu sehen als die Chancen und kommen dann teilweise auch mit Sachen, die wenn man eine Ahnung vom Internet hat und die durchdenkt, nur zu dem Schluss kommen kann, haben die sie nach alle.
Aber ist das denn nicht ein bisschen zu kurz gegriffen? Also so wie du es gerade erzählt hast, heißt es ja sagen, es gibt eine junge Generation, die kennt das Internet, es gibt eine alte Generation, die kennt das nicht. Ich werde dir die Behauptung aufstellen, dass es durchaus Leute gibt, also in eurer Generation, auch die das Internet sehr wohl kennen, die aber trotzdem das mit der Sicherheit ist eine super Idee.
Ich wollte mich auch nicht auf die Generationenfrage beschränken, sondern natürlich haben wir auch verschiedene Ausprägungen von Weltbildern in unserer Gesellschaft. Und wenn ich jetzt in der CSU bin und den ganzen Tag den Mümmelmann als Terroristen vor mir als Feindbild sehe, dann habe ich einen anderen Zugang zu dem Thema Terrorismus im Internet als die Leute, die den ganzen Tag das Internet ganz selbstverständlich nutzen und produktiv damit sind.
Obwohl, wir können das auch nicht wirklich über einen Kamm scheren, also hier im Europaparlament gibt es schon einige Abgeordnete, die sich sehr gut auskennen und da sind alle Generationen mit dabei und das sind Abgeordnete aus allen Parteien.
Wird das Problem dann jemals geklärt oder ist das dann so eine Art Syphosarbeit, man rollt den Stein der Internetfreiheit immer wieder den Berg hoch?
Ich glaube, dass es am Ende ein Abwägen von Interessen ist. Totale Freiheit führt am Ende vielleicht auch zu einem Missbrauch dieser Freiheiten. Natürlich muss man Extrempositionen versuchen zu verteidigen, um sich dann irgendwann in einem gesellschaftlichen Konsens wiederzufinden. Aber dass der Stein immer wieder den Berg runterfällt in letzter Zeit sehe ich nicht so. Wir haben Flöcke eingerammt, hinter die einfach nicht mehr zurückgegangen werden kann. Und dieses CleanIT-Projekt mit den Forderungen, die jetzt dort auftauchen, da ist die Hälfte einfach schon komplett so lebensfremd, dass sich keiner mehr trauen würde, der ein Amt bekleidet oder gewählt wurde, die dann öffentlich zu wiederholen. Und wir sollten einfach versuchen, Steine hochrollen und mit der neuen Pfahl einrahmen und so weiter.
Aber heißt das dann, was man sich sagen muss, eigentlich über dieses Ding keine Sorgen mehr machen muss, weil es eh noch Quatsch ist?
Und das CleanIT? Das war ja mein Eingangsstatement.
Ist es vielleicht noch ein kleiner Unterschied, möchte ich vielleicht fragen?
Ich glaube, dass das Papier an sich nützlich für uns ist, um zu sehen, was da gerade noch die Themen auf der Agenda sind. Weil die werden ja auch gegoogelt haben, um zu gucken, was man da gerade noch als Begründung anführen kann. Haben uns damit die Arbeit gespart. Aber ansonsten wird es natürlich immer wieder Leute geben, die automatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung, dieses Automatic Policing, ist eigentlich ein großes Thema für die Zukunft. Was dann passiert, was mit einer Gesellschaft passiert, wenn du es schaffst, sämtliche Handlungen einer Person automatisch zu bestrafen, zu was für einer Normierung das führt. Wie auch eine automatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung, die auch von irgendwelchen privaten Firmen dann ohne jegliche Abwägung durchgeführt wird, die die Verhältnismäßigkeit dann nicht beachten. Man stelle sich halt nur vor, wenn einfach die Gesellschaft keinerlei Spielraum mehr gibt, dann wäre die gesamte Schwulenbewegung heute komplett nicht existenz, weil er war ja illegal. Und erst weil diese Leute dann durch an die Öffentlichkeit treten, illegale Dinge zu propagieren, den gesellschaftlichen Konsens verschoben haben, war es erst möglich, dass sich die Gesellschaft weiterentwickelt hat. Und deswegen müssen wir natürlich als eine demokratischen, freie Gesellschaft immer noch immer weiter dafür kämpfen, dass nicht Maschinen am Ende darüber entscheiden, in automatisierten Algorithmen, wie wir uns verhalten und dann de facto außerhalb des Gesetzes noch mal ein ganz eigenes Gesetz schaffen. Weil was nämlich passiert, wenn Firmen in ihren AGBs oder in ihren automatischen Filtern bestimmen können, was im Internet passiert und was nicht, dass ein ziemlich signifikanter Bereich des Lebens automatisiert poliest wird. Genau, kontrolliert wird.
Jetzt, ich muss zu einer Sache zurückkommen, die du gerade gesagt hast, das ist nämlich die mit den Maximalforderungen. Du sagst es selber gerade, dass man so macht. Man stellt dann erstmal eine Extremforderung und dann trifft man sich irgendwo in der Mitte. Könnte man also auch sagen, diese ganzen Sicherheitsforderungen sind eigentlich auch nur, weil die andere Seite das genauso macht, sind auch nur so Extremforderungen, die sozusagen den Beginn des Falschens markieren und dann trifft man sich irgendwo. Also die wollen das eigentlich auch gar nicht so hart?
Na dafür war es dann aber echt schlecht abgeguckt.
Und ich glaube, dass wirklich professionelle Politiker das schon ein bisschen subtiler gemacht hätten und das Ganze irgendwie in Worten irgendwo, in irgendwelchen Gesetzestexten noch untergeschoben hätten, also dass dieses CleanIT Projekt, das war wirklich eine Sache von Amateuren.
Okay, okay, lass mal einfach so zu sehen, aber ich würde jetzt sagen, ich würde dann noch mal vermuten, okay, sie machen das, dann hat man so das ganz Extrem abgesteckt und darüber gelacht. Und dann das nächste, was man bringt, ist dann sozusagen so 75 Prozent auf dem Weg zum Extrem. Man sagt so, okay, wir haben jetzt mal ernsthafte Vorschläge gemacht und dann müsste man darüber dann schon wieder ernsthaft reden. Aber eine andere Diskussion, die gerade hier im Chat losgetreten wird und der Herr ruft leider nicht an. Herrgott, 0331 70 97 111. Wir haben doch jetzt schon das Telefon. Bring das nochmal hier. Ich finde es aber ganz spannend, deswegen will ich das mal einfach hier hin übertragen. Er sagt, es wird zu wenig mit den Leuten geredet und da hat Ilf, der auch hier im Studio sitzt im Chat, gesagt, na ja, aber die EDRI hat doch gesagt, unter folgenden Voraussetzungen reden wir mit denen. Darum ging es ihm aber nicht, sondern er sagt, es wird allgemein zu wenig mit der anderen Seite kommuniziert, im Sinne von, dass man denen so ein bisschen pädagogisch was beibringt, habe ich das Gefühl. Und da gab es ja sozusagen, da gab es in Deutschland so ein Vorfall, der Herr Guttenberg, der uns allen gut bekannt ist, durch das Abschreiben seiner, oder was ist nicht Abschreiben, man weiß es nicht so genau, aber der ist ja jetzt, nachdem er Verteidigungsminister war, ist er jetzt für Internetfreiheit irgendwie da in der EU zugange und hat sich ja mit jemand getroffen, der Internetaktivistisch in Deutschland ist, nämlich Stefan Obach und davon gab es, da gab es halt viel Feuerwehr, allein für die Tatsache, dass die beiden miteinander reden. Ist das jetzt so, dass ihr als Aktivisten sagt, also es lohnt sich eigentlich gar nicht mit denen zu reden, weil das verschwendet liebes Mühe ist?
Na nicht nur, es gibt denen auch so eine gewisse Autorität noch dazu. Seht mal, wir trauen ihm da so viel Gravitas und so viel Einfluss in diesen Themen zu, dass es sich lohnt, sich mit ihm zusammenzusetzen. Also muss der ja da schon irgendeinen Peil von der Materie haben und das will man einfach so Leuten nicht entleben. Ich würde den Gutenberg jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass er sich mit Netzthemen so gut auskennt, dass er uns da in Europa vertreten würde. Und das hätte wahrscheinlich den Anstrich gehabt, wenn wir uns mit ihm hingesetzt haben. Und ich glaube nicht, dass er uns irgendwas Sinnvolles zu diesem Thema hätte erzählen können.
Naja, aber ihr ihm.
Und dann?
Naja, der hat ja diesen Posten jetzt. Meinst du, das ist wirklich nur so ein Geld-Einsack-Ding? Der hat da gar nichts zu melden? Also wäre das nicht die Chance gewesen, eine Idee dahin zu tragen?
Als ob der dort unsere Ideen vertreten würde.
Naja, also möglicherweise wahrscheinlich nicht, aber man weiß es ja nicht. So, Ilf schlägt gerade die Hände über dem Kopf zusammen und die platzt gleich. Was ist denn los?
Also sowohl zu Guttenberg als auch zu der Chat-Diskussion. Wir verschließen uns doch nicht Diskussionen. Ganz im Gegenteil. Wir werden erfreut, wenn manche Leute die Politik machen möchten und uns einmal öfters fragen und unseren Sachverstand mit zur Rate ziehen, statt irgendein Zeug vorzuschlagen, was nicht nur technisch total daneben ist.
Ja, aber da muss ich jetzt auch mit den Armen wieder sagen, das hat der Guttenberg doch versucht.
Herr Guttenberg war eine ganz besondere Situation. Herr Guttenberg ist ein deutscher Minister gewesen, der der Lüge entlarvt wurde, der dann aus der Politik ausgeschieden ist, einen Sabbatiger machen wollte und von der Bild betraut wurde, dass er doch bitte wieder zurückkommen soll. Und diesen Versuch wieder in die deutsche Politik zurückzukommen, hat er tatsächlich unternommen und er hat dafür eine Torte ins Gesicht bekommen und sich seitdem nicht wieder in Deutschland politisch blicken lassen.
Ja, und da könnte man jetzt sozusagen, um diese Position auch zu drinnen sagen, so, na das ist ja super, da hat sozusagen mal jemand, der tatsächlich wegen schlechten Voraussetzungen das Gespräch gesucht hat, also möglicherweise wollte er sich dann nicht schmücken, aber es war halt eine Gelegenheit. Und alles, was einem einfällt, ist ihm ein Tort ins Gesicht zu werfen. Ich meine, kann man, erzielt man so Leute?
Das war Herr von und zu, ich bin erschüttert, Guttenberg, der einfach seine Visionen des Internets und was er dort bereit ist, nach draußen zu tragen, schon dort einfach klar und deutlich manifestiert hat. Ich denke, das ist echt vergebene Liebesmühe. Und man würde ihn noch adeln, wenn man sich mit ihnen unterhält. Und deswegen dachte ich, dass diese gefrorene Torte da auch schon ganz angemessen war, die er da abbekommen hat.
Also es ist vielleicht generell so, dass es helfen könnte, wenn man da noch einen Schritt mehr drauf zugeht, ein bisschen mehr investiert, statt immer nur sozusagen die brennenden Ruinen einzureißen, damit das Feuer nicht überspringt?
Na, der Klaas Computer Club setzt sich da auch immer mit den up-and-coming-Politikern zusammen und versucht dann in Hintergrundgesprächen, denen so Dinge zu erklären, dass wir ja nicht, keine Ahnung, wollen, dass hier allkeiner Ausbildungsnetzwerke in Deutschland entstehen, weil wir es einfach für komplett unrealistisch halten. Wir unterhalten uns da auch, aber wir hängen es halt nicht so plakativ auf. Also wir vermitteln da schon unsere Agenda, aber wir wollen nicht, dass sich dann irgendeine politische Partei da mit dem Label schmückt, dass sie da CCC-approved politics betreiben würde.
Also das wollte ich jetzt auch noch sagen, also der ganze Sinn und Zweck von EDRI ist es ja auch hier in Brüssel die ganze Zeit mit Leuten zu reden. Also wir reden, reden, reden von morgens bis abends und ich habe ja eben schon mal gesagt, also wir werden auch zu Expertengruppen eingeladen von der Kommission und wir machen in super vielen Gruppen mit zur RFID, zu dem Internet der Dinge, zu Notice and Take Down und also uns vorzuwerfen, dass wir mit den Leuten nicht reden, das ist ja schon dreist.
Man muss es aber mal gefragt haben. Wir werden gleich noch eine halbe Stunde sozusagen versuchen, die ganze Sache zu einem runden Abschluss zu bringen und machen vorab eine kleine Pause und zwar wie ihr sicherlich möglicherweise schon vermut habt, fürs Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Live und neu und gut.
Wann genau und wo genau? Fritzee. Lexi und Kay Paul. Live von neu und gut.
Empfohlen von Fritz.
Und das hört man um kurz vor halb 12. Nachrichten mit Jonte Weyland.
In Ostdeutschland sind mehr als 4.000 Kinder und Jugendliche an verunreinigtem Essen erkrankt. Ein Sprecher des Robert-Koch-Instituts sagte, dass Berlin, Brandenburg, Sachsen und Thüringen betroffen sind. Nach RBB-Informationen sind in Brandenburg mehr als 1.100 Kinder und Jugendliche erkrankt, in Berlin etwa 400. Auslöser ist wahrscheinlich das Essen des Großanbieters für Kita- und Schulessen Sodexo aus Thüringen. Inzwischen ist auch das Bundesamt für Verbraucherschutz und Lebensmittelsicherheit eingeschaltet worden. Der ständige Euro-Rettungsschirm ESM kommt. Heute Nachmittag hat Bundespräsident Gauck die Ratifizierungsurkunde unterschrieben. Damit kann der Rettungsschirm in knapp zwei Wochen in Kraft treten. Er hat eine Höhe von 500 Milliarden Euro und soll pleite bedrohte Euroländer unterstützen. Deutschland beteiligt sich am Rettungsschirm mit maximal 190 Milliarden Euro. Berlins Inn-Senator Henkel muss nicht vor dem NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss des Bundestages aussagen. Die Ausschussmitglieder wiesen einen Antrag der Grünen ab. Auch Berlins Polizeipräsidentin Koppers wird nicht vorgeladen. Die Grünen wollen Henkel zu seinen Erkenntnissen zur Faumann-Affäre befragen. Zuletzt war bekannt geworden, dass die Berliner Polizei jahrelang mit dem mutmaßlichen NSU-Unterstützer Thomas S zusammengearbeitet hat. Diese Informationen waren dem Untersuchungsausschuss mehr als ein halbes Jahr vorenthalten worden. Henkel hat inzwischen einen Sonderermittler eingesetzt. Trotz heftiger Proteste in der Bevölkerung will die spanische Regierung ihre Sparbemühungen im kommenden Jahr noch einmal verstärken. Das Kabinett verabschiedete in Madrid den Etatentwurf für 2013. Finanzminister Montoro sagte, dass 40 Milliarden Euro eingespart werden sollen. Die Etats der Ministerien sollen um durchschnittlich 12% gekürzt werden. Die Gehälter der Beamten und der Angestellten im öffentlichen Dienst werden für ein weiteres Jahr eingefroren. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin haben wir es überall zwischen 14 und 15 Grad, Wittenberge 11, Angermünde 12, Neuropin 13 und Potsdam, Cottbus und Frankfurt melden 14 Grad. Nachts bleibt es weiter regnerisch und wolkig, erst später lockert es dann etwas auf und die Temperaturen sinken auf 12 bis 10 Grad. Morgen wird es dann wieder regnerisch und wolkig und das Ganze bei 15 bis 18 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin Tiergartenstraße des 17. Juni. Zwischen Jetzakrabinstraße und Brandenburger Tor gibt es eine Vollsperrung wegen der Vorbereitung zum Berlin-Marathon. Ab morgen früh um 6 Uhr wird die Sperrung bis zum Großen Stern erweitert. Der Kreisverkehr rund um die Siegessäule bleibt jedoch frei. Gesperrt wird außerdem die Jetzakrabinstraße sowie die Ebertstraße zwischen Bärenstraße und Scheidemannstraße. Und dann noch nach Brandenburg A10 nördlicher Berliner Ringrichtung, Dreieck Haveland zwischen Mühlenbeck und Birkenwerder befinden sich Personen auf der Fahrbahn. Fahrt hier also bitte besonders vorsichtig. Sonst überall, wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB. Und wenn ihr den Fritz Night Flight von letzter Nacht verpasst habt oder ihn einfach noch mal hören wollt, dann hört ihn doch einfach noch mal.
So oft ihr wollt und wann ihr wollt.
Eine Woche lang im Musikstream. Auf FritzD.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Zu Gast vom Chaos Computer Club sind Ilf und Erdgeist. Hallo und guten Abend noch mal. Außerdem Andre Meister vom Blog Netzpolitik. Hallo und guten Abend. Und Kirsten Fiedler von EDRI. Eine Advocacy-Gruppe. Gibt es auch ein deutsches Wort für eigentlich?
Bürgerrechtsorganisation.
Eine Bürgerrechtsorganisation in Brüssel. Drei Leute versorgen dort das gesamte europäische Parlament. Wir haben heute geredet über Clean IT und über die Art und Weise, wie in der, wie in Europa Sicherheitspolitik gemacht wird. Ich möchte jetzt gerne sozusagen noch eine kurze Frage stellen. Wir haben auch schon darüber geredet, was dieses Projekt war, woher der Gedanke kommt, dass sowas immer wieder passiert. Und die einzige Frage ist jetzt, wie handeln wir das in Zukunft? Kirsten, erst mal nach Brüssel. Was sind denn so die konkreten Pläne? Was steht denn als nächstes an in dieser Richtung? Oder ist jetzt mit Clean IT endlich alles gegessen und wir haben unsere Ruhe?
Ja, schön wär's. Dann könnte ich einpacken und nach Hause gehen. Also ja, wie gesagt, Clean IT ist ja nur ein einziges Symptom eines allgemeinen Trends. Und im Moment gibt es noch andere Projekte, wie zum Beispiel die CEO Coalition, wo es um Kinder- und Jugendschutz geht. Und da machen auch alle möglichen Unternehmen mit, unter anderem Microsoft, Google, Facebook und so weiter. Und die haben sich in Arbeitsgruppen unterteilt. Und zwar hat Microsoft die Arbeitsgruppe Notice and Take Down inne. Facebook hat den Vorsitz der Arbeitsgruppe Datenschutz.
Ich hätte das gerne noch mal langsam. Facebook hat den Vorsitz in einer Arbeitsgruppe, die erst um Datenschutz geht.
Datenschutz, genau. Aber das wirklich lustige, also eher gesagt traurige in der letzten Zeit, waren die Diskussionen in der Arbeitsgruppe Notice and Take Down. Und da ging es auch um alle möglichen freiwilligen Maßnahmen, die Unternehmen durchführen sollten. Und unter anderem hat Microsoft da halt enthusiastisch für die Firmen eigene FotoDNA-Software geworben. Das Ding soll irgendwie Bilder analysieren. Das ist quasi ein Upload-Filter wie Content ID. Die analysiert Bilder, die Missbrauch darstellen, selbst wenn die geschnitten oder verzerrt wurden. Und dann soll das halt weitere Uploads verhindern.
Dann habt ihr also auf jeden Fall genug zu tun. Jetzt sitzt möglicherweise da jemand vor seinem neuartigen Rundfunk-Empfangsgerät und denkt sich so, die armen drei Leute in Brüssel machen die Arbeit ganz alleine. Was kann ich tun?
Also was die Leute tun können, ist sich weiterhin informieren. Also wir veröffentlichen ziemlich viel auf der EDRI-Webseite. Oder halt auf öffentliche Konzentration der EU-Kommission antworten. Oder halt den ganzen tollen Organisationen, die die Arbeit machen, ein bisschen Geld zukommen zu lassen.
Was war das gerade das Vorliege, was du gesagt hast? Öffentliche Konsultation? Was genau ist das?
Also, bevor die EU-Kommission einen Gesetzesvorschlag vorlegt, startet sie normalerweise öffentliche Konsultation. Da kann dann jeder darauf antworten. Und das ist wirklich ganz wichtig, dass auch Bürgerinnen und Bürger und alle möglichen Bürgerrechtsorganisationen das auch machen. Weil sonst antwortet halt nur die Industrie.
Ah ja, da kann man sich also sagen, selber mal einbringen. Quasi die Stimme des Bürgers. Habt ihr gehört, Leute? Kirsten, dann vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen.
Eine letzte Anmerkung hatte ich noch. Kirsten, seid doch nicht so bescheiden. Auch EDRI lebt von diesem komischen Geld, von dem die Leute schon mal gehört haben. Das ist echt wichtig. Wie gesagt, vor zwei Jahren war Joe leider noch alleine. Jetzt gibt es immerhin drei Leute, aber auch das sind noch viel zu wenige, um die ganzen Sachen, die da in Brüssel und drum herum passieren, monitoren und begleiten zu können. Auf der Seite edri.org gibt es links einen Banner Spenden. Denn wie andere Organisationen auch, lebt und braucht auch EDRI Spenden von Leuten, die das für eine gute Sache halten, aber sich jetzt vielleicht nicht im Gestrüpp von Kommissionen, DGs und Parlamenten auskennen.
Also wenn euch das so kompliziert ist, bewerft ihr doch da einfach mit Geld.
Ja, danke euch.
Und viel Glück bei der Arbeit in Brüssel noch. So, da haben wir also in Brüssel einen Einblick hinter die Brüsseler Kulissen gehabt. Wie sieht es bei euch aus? Andre, du machst ja für Netzpolitik ganz viel. Wie macht ihr da sozusagen einfach weiter Berichterstattung? Wie ist das eigentlich? Macht ihr das da manchmal im Sinne von Vorausberichterstattung oder wartet ihr einfach, dass der nächste Skandal kommt und seid dann immer fleißig dabei? Du hast ja jetzt heute zum Beispiel noch so eine Rede transkribiert von irgendeinem EU-Politiker. Wird das so weiterlaufen?
Also Netzpolitik beobachtet natürlich schon seit Jahren und hat fest vor, dass auch weiterhin zu tun alle möglichen Themen, die rund um Politik und Internet in beide Richtungen zu tun haben. Wir können auch nicht immer voraussehen, was als nächstes aufpoppen wird. Wir sind da auf die Mitarbeit von Bündnisorganisationen, vom Chaos Computer Club, aber auch EDRI, anderen Netzwerken, die wir so haben, angewiesen. Und manchmal passiert es auch andersrum, dass Leute auf uns zukommen und wir einen kleinen Scoop landen können mit einer Nachricht, die vorher noch niemand auf dem Schirm hatte.
Gibt es sozusagen konkret Verdacht, was in einem Monat unser aufregendes Tagesende wird?
Drohnen. Drohnen? Wieso? Drohnen sind coole Spielzeuge und mit Drohnen kann man überwachen.
Gibt es auch aus EU-Perl aus?
Das wird auf jeden Fall kommen. Ich weiß nicht wer, aber irgendjemand wird dann mal den, keine Ahnung, wenn im Spiegel mal wieder oder in einer Zeit so ein Artikel drüber ist und findet einen Lokalpolitiker, dass es eine gute Idee ist, und dann lässt er sich das erklären von seinem Neffen. Und dann kann ich mir ganz gut vorstellen, dass da die nächste große Kampagne...
Wie drängt es jetzt gerade für mich die Fahrer auf? Habt ihr, ich sage immer jetzt ja ihr, so global ihr Aktivisten, habt ihr so kleine Wetten, also Fußballfans haben ja so ein Tippspiel. Habt ihr so Wetten am Laufen, so ok, das nächste alberne Gesetz, das vorgeschlagen wird?
Ja, also im Wohnzimmer sitzen wir und gucken dann, ob als nächstes wieder Naziskinder, Pädophile oder Terroristen oder was wieder auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt wird immer.
Ah, ok, also es wird nicht gewettet, welches schlimme Gesetz als nächstes kommt, sondern wie es begründet wird. Ok, dann hatten wir jetzt gerade Terroristen mit Clean IT. Was wird denn das nächste dann sein?
Muss man mal an den Turnus gucken. Ich habe eine Wette auf, dass demnächst wieder Kindesmissbrauch kommt.
Ok, gut, werden wir dann an gegebener Stelle hier berichten. Wir schließen damit das Thema ab. Es sei denn, ihr habt jetzt noch eine ganz dringende Frage. Dann hättet ihr jetzt auch noch Zeit unter 0331 77 97 120 anzurufen. Wir haben aber noch ein paar kleine Hausmeistereien für euch. Also der Club hat ein paar Daten, die am Start sind, Herr Erdgeist.
Genau so sind Datenspuren, die in Dresden stattfinden. Das ist vor am 13. und 14. Oktober. Und die Dresdner haben eigentlich seit Jahren ein ziemlich cooles Programm, was es sehr gut schafft, Technik und Politik auf eine spannende Art und Weise zusammenzuführen, in Form von Vorträgen und Workshops. Und das ist irgendwie auch eine total familiäre Atmosphäre. Und ich kann da zu den Datenspuren eigentlich immer nur...
Also wie das Chaosradio nur zwei Tage lang?
Ja, mit Anfassen.
Ich sehe dein leises, bedauernder Stimme. Gibt es noch mehr? Warte, du hattest glaube ich die Tage noch gar nicht gesagt.
Doch, doch hatte ich 13. Das 14. Oktober. Und auf datenspuren.de stehen eigentlich alle spannenden Informationen dazu. Alright. Ansonsten wollte, glaube ich... Nö, sonst habe ich hier nur Nachrichten. Der Datengarten in Berlin ist nämlich just heute parallel zu der Sendung. Deswegen kann ich da leider nicht mehr drauf referenzieren. Da ist heute eine Wikiergruppe, die davon berichtet, wie sie Wikipedia maschinenlesbarer hinbekommt. Und finde ich eigentlich einen ganz spannenden Punkt, den ich jetzt wegen des Chaosradios gar nicht live mitmachen kann.
Du guter. Unter aller Dank ist dir gewiss. Man kann aber dazu sagen, der Datengarten ist eine regelmäßige Veranstaltung, oder?
Inzwischen wieder regelmäßige Veranstaltung, ja.
Kann man sich da irgendwo informieren an Stellen, die gepflegt werden?
Berlinccc.de, das ist ein Wiki. Dort versuchen wir einigermaßen regelmäßig abzudaten, was bei uns im Club in der Marienstraße 11 in Mitte so abgeht.
Alles klar, könnt aber gucken. Wir kommen jetzt zu den Nachrichten. Ich habe hier ein paar Schlagzeilen. Ich werde die mal vortragen. Du sagst bitte, worum es genau geht. Ich schreibe zum Beispiel als erste Schlagzeile Sternchen 2767, Sternchen 3855 Raute.
Wer einen Samsung Galaxy 3 hat, der hat gerade echt Freunde. Wenn er nämlich diesen MMI in sein Telefon eingeht, dann wird ein Factory Reset durchgeführt. Und das heißt, dass man dann so ziemlich alle Dateneinstellungen und so ziemlich alles wieder verliert, was man da auf seinem Telefon veranstaltet hat. Was wirklich fiese ist, dass man diesen Vendor Implemented MMI sich auch von Remote ausführen lassen kann, indem man einfach auf der Webseite, die man besucht, einen DIV. Man kann auf eine Webseite gehen.
Ganz ruhig. Erklärst du das so, dass es alle verstehen?
Ich bin so doll aufgeregt, weil ich das so witzig finde. Man kann, ähnlich wie früher die ersten Exploits für Browser passiert sind, dass man bestimmte Dinge fernsteuern kann, wie zum Beispiel einen Kalkulator-Exe aufrufen. Wenn der Internet Explorer sich über Listen lässt, kann man dieses Telefon auch dazu bringen, diesen Factory Reset beim Besuch einer Webseite auszuführen.
Also ihr geht mit eurem Mobiltelefon auf eine Webseite und es macht zonk und dann ist das Mobiltelefon wieder so, als ob ihr es gerade ganz frisch ausgepackt hättet. Das ist ja total großartig und da möchte ich nur mal sagen, apropos Internet Explorer. Was war da nochmal los? Niemand weiß, dass genau der Internet Explorer hatte. Ich kam mir wirklich vor, wie in der guten alten Zeit. Es gab mal wieder ein Sicherheitslöck im Internet Explorer. Früher kannte man das, da gab es das jeden Monat irgendwie. Tatsächlich kamen jetzt raus, der Internet Explorer 6, 7, 8, 9 und 10 hat eine Sicherheitslücke, die so schlimm ist, dass man auf der Besuch an der Webseite ausreicht, dass man komplett den Rechner übernehmen kann. Das fand ich ganz großartig.
Ich kenne halt niemanden mehr, der den Internet Explorer ernsthaft einsetzt.
Das ist Monoxid.
Entschuldigung, nur auf meinem Arbeitsrechner.
Der liest ja auch vom Radio das Internet vor.
Was? Das würde ich niemals tun.
Doch, vorhin aus dem Chat.
Jetzt wird mir hier die Hörerbeteiligung vorgebracht. Ich fand diese Meinung tatsächlich so spannend, weil in Kreisen von Leuten, die so technikaffin sind, da ist genau das die Reaktion so, ach guck mir, Internet Explorer benützt doch eh keiner mehr. Aber ich glaube tatsächlich, das ist tatsächlich auch noch gefährlich.
Dann ruft Mutti an.
Genau, dann ruft Mutti an. Oder der Arbeitsadmin, dem sagt man das, und der guckt dich so an so, haaaaa? Also ich finde, so eine Nachricht sollte man trotzdem noch verfolgen. Dann habe ich hier etwas zu Kimbell und dem Premierminister von Neuseeland. Was ist da passiert?
Kimbell ist ja ein aus Deutschland ausgewanderter toller Hecht, der damals durch das Verpetzen seiner Kumpels hier und Verkaufen von raubkopierter Software sich einen doch ziemlich schlechten Namen gemacht hat. Und der hat ja mega upload aufgezogen und sich eine goldene Nase verdient. Und nachdem die Amerikaner in Neuseeland ein bisschen Druck gemacht haben, wurde er dort vom Geheimdienst eine Weile überwacht und illegal abgehört und dann in einer ziemlich martialischen Aktion auch festgenommen und für mehrere Tage eingesperrt. Und für das illegale Abhören hat sich heute der Premierminister von Neuseeland öffentlich entschuldigt bei ihm. Soweit ist es also gekommen, dass irgendwelche, möchte gern super Spezialhacker unsere Sympathie abbekommen müssen, weil sie in die Mühlen eines wild frei drehenden, ehemaligen Rechtsstaats geraten sind.
So, da hab ich gehört, irgendwo wird Pfeilscheren legal?
Ja, Pfeilscheren für private Zwecke ist inzwischen in Portugal, naja, nicht legal, aber der Staatsanwalt, der Generalstaatsanwalt hat wegen der Fülle von Fällen, die dort jetzt verhandelt werden sollen, einmal ein generelles Verfolgungsstopp für Pfeilscheren auf privater Ebene verhangen. Das heißt also, dass das Massenabmahn-Geschäft, wie in Deutschland und Portugal eigentlich hier gerade verboten wurde.
Besteht da Hoffnung, dass man es möglicherweise übernimmt? Nein.
Nein, das wäre bestimmt schon mal eine tolle Sendung, wenn wir die nicht schon gemacht hätten.
So, dann gibt es eine Crypto-Party.
Ja, es gibt eine Crypto-Party, in der, ja, wie heißt das? Evangelisten, nein Evangelisten sind die, die Evangelien aufschreiben. Die Leute, die andere Leute zu Cryptografie bekehren wollen, sich zusammentreffen und ich soll auf die Crypto-Party hinweisen, aber jetzt nicht speziell auf die nächste in Berlin, weil die auch schon sehr überlaufen ist. Aber auf cryptoparty.org kann man sich in seiner Nähe das nächste Meeting da mal heraussuchen und dort einfach partizipieren, um sich vielleicht einen generellen Überblick über Alltags-Cryptografie, was man so an PGP benutzen kann, wie man in seinem Browser sich die Zertifikate angucken soll, um diesen Überblick zu bekommen. Und ich war da noch nicht bei gewesen, aber Leute, denen ich vertraue, dass die da schon ein cleveres Händchen für Veranstaltungen haben, haben wir dir empfohlen, dort darauf hinzuweisen.
Und falls ihr dennoch mal vorbeigucken wollt, noch einen kleinen Platz ergattern wollt am 28. September, ist das glaube ich in Berlin. Aber wie gesagt, Crypto Party Org. So, dann sind wir eigentlich durch, oder? Es ist jetzt 23.48 Uhr?
Ja, du hast einfach zu schnell geredet.
Ich habe überhaupt gar nichts gesagt.
Also ich sehe da noch mindestens eins auf der Liste. Ja bitte? Open Plan B. Ein Open Data Projekt von befreundeten Aktivisten, die schon seit einer ganzen Weile mit Verkehrsunternehmen diskutieren, die auf riesigen Datenbergen sitzen, von ihren Fahrplänen und Haltestellen, Orten und all möglichen Informationen dazu, die zwar überall aushängen, die es aber noch nicht wirklich digital für alle gibt. Jetzt hat gerade Google einen Deal mit der Deutschen Bahn gemacht, um in Google Maps zu integrieren, wenn man von Ort A nach Ort B im roten Planer will, dass dann auch öffentliche Verkehrsmittel angezeigt werden. Nur leider hat nur Google diese Daten von der Deutschen Bahn bekommen, was ein Unding ist, weil wir, also die Deutsche Bahn war immer Staatsunternehmer, bzw. der Staat hält immer noch die größten Anteile. Wir haben dafür bezahlt, wir wollen die Daten auch haben und vor allem wir können viel coolere Sachen damit machen, als die Deutsche Bahn das selber kann. Also ist Michael Kreil hingegangen, ein befreundeter Open Data Aktivist, hat die Windows-Offline-Fahrplan-App oder irgend so ein Zeug von der Webseite runtergeladen, wo der ganze Fahrplan in obskuren Datenformaten drin war, hat das befreit in ein normales Datenformat gemacht und hat das auf BitTorrent gestellt. Das heißt, die Fahrplandaten der Deutschen Bahn und einige andere Verkehrsunternehmen, unter anderem der Verkehrsverbund Berlin, Brandenburg, VBB, sind jetzt auf BitTorrent frei für alle herunterladbar. Mehr Open Data für alle.
Aber dabei halten Sie doch, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, eher um einen symbolischen Akt als um etwas Praktisches, oder?
Nee, das heißt doch, wie die Datensätze in Offline zur Verfügung zu haben, ist doch Sahne. Die ganze Zeit die Bahn querien zu müssen und zu gucken und dass Ihre Server dich dann nicht irgendwann filtern, sondern einfach das bei dir lokal selber mal nachzugucken, ob dir wirklich die Bahn immer die günstigste Verbindung raussucht oder ob man vielleicht noch bessere Ideen hat, wie man Routing wichten kann. Vielleicht, ja, ich habe ein Fahrrad, wie komme ich denn am besten durch die Gegend? Also kleine, ziemlich coole Gadgets, die die Bahn dir nicht anbietet, kannst du endlich selber rechnen auf den Datenmuster nicht durch deren hässliches, ich habe nicht genau verstanden, ob jetzt mit Friedrichstraße S war nur Friedrichstraße oder Friedrichstraße irgendwo draußen in Steglitz Mainz. Ist doch viel, viel cooler, wenn man mit dem Datenmaterial selber spielen kann.
Ist das jetzt sozusagen, wurde das dann auch zum Anlass genommen, dass die Meilen sagt, naja gut, dann nehmt doch lieber unsere richtigen Daten? Oder ist das jetzt einfach nur dieses Ding, ist jetzt im Netz und das war es dann auch wieder?
Die Deutsche Bahn sperrt sich leider noch ein bisschen. Andere wie der VBB hier in Berlin und Brandenburg sind weiter und wollen tatsächlich demnächst ihre kompletten Fahrplandaten in einem offenen Format für alle zum Download unter einer freien Lizenz zur freien Verwendung zur Verfügung stellen. Irgendwie hat die Deutsche Bahn das noch nicht so ganz kapiert. Da sind halt, und da sind wir wieder bei den Generationenproblemen, noch viele Hindernisse und Ängste vor diesem Internet. Da könnte ja irgendjemand eine schlechte Deutsche Bahn Fahrplan-App machen. Wie es zum Beispiel eine bestimmte schon ist. Ich glaube, die könnten alle nur noch besser werden. Wenn man die Kreativität der Masse da drauf loslässt, dann werden da auch tolle Sachen daraus entstehen.
Ich muss jetzt auch unbedingt mal das Internet vorlesen, weil da geht gerade durch den Chat noch, dass der Internet Explorer wird wohl noch von mindestens so 33% der Surfer verwendet. Ich weiß zwar nicht, wo das Zitat her ist, aber ich mag dieses Wort Surfer. Da schwingt immer Silversurfer mit, wie keine Ahnung, so komisch verdrahtet.
Es gibt doch dieses schöne Lied.
Ist das das, was du nur am Ende der Sendung spielst?
Nee, das ist ein anderes. Da haben wir noch ein bisschen Zeit für.
Noch ein anderes.
Ich bin wirklich ein bisschen erschüttert und gerade ein bisschen auch sprachlos. Sprach und ratlos.
Wieso? Das Internet Explorer ist wegen?
Nee, wegen der Zeit.
Ach so.
Aber glücklicherweise ist er für die 15 Jahre Chaosradio und das ist noch nie passiert. Aber von dieser lustigen Creative Commons Musik habe ich natürlich noch einen kleinen Song dabei. Und da geht es, das kommen wir vielleicht auch auf die EU-Politik, beziehend um einen großen Fisch. Ne, zwei. Ich danke euch nämlich, Ilf, Andre und Erdgeist, dass ihr jeweils und das noch mal genauer erklärt habt. Und mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich bitte euch, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Pack-Ups.